to learn the syntax of the code
we can see the text inside the console
it has three lines the first one is a
comment so
we use a hash sign to comment out any
text or use it to annotate the code so
it's easier to read
then there are two lines these are used
to call a package by its name and assign
it with a name that will later be used
to call functions from the library
functions that the package contains
once the packages are loaded you can
hover over the small i icon to see which
packages have been actually loaded
to load the data set you need to create
an object any name can be used for
example you can use df or data frame or
any name like gene expression but
without the spaces or unusual characters
to view the data simply refer to the
object name and it will be printed out
in the console
once the data is loaded you can perform
many functions on different parts of the
data you can call a specific row column
or cell this will be extremely useful as
we prepare the data for analysis